women in business as well as women in
leadership positions in any sector have
been something that I've been very
concerned about my entire professional
life and I have to say it was selfish
because I got my PhD at a time when
there were very few people like me I was
often the first of my kind sitting in a
room with people of another kind that
sometimes true by the way when I go as
an American to the Middle East now where
I'm very different in many respects so I
was very concerned about getting more
women I thought it was in my
self-interest to have my women
colleagues first of all then the whole
image of women would would have been
elevated but also I wouldn't have had to
sit there and answer silly questions
about what's the woman's point of view
there I wanted more at the table I also
do care about opportunity and I care
about not breaking not being confined I
care about I care about opportunity and
I care about not being trapped behind
stereotypes so now we've had the
breakthroughs there's certainly more
women in leadership positions and lots
and lots of women in the pipeline what
I'm concerned about now is that we
haven't changed institutions enough to
make it possible for women who want to
devote themselves to their children
during formative years to do that or for
men for that matter who say no I'd like
to devote my time to my children to do
that without feeling they sacrifice
their careers I think we still don't
have enough women in leadership to make
it totally normal or we wouldn't ask
today's silly woman question which is
was Carly Fiorina fired because she was
a woman and the answer is no she wasn't
but all the attention she got afterwards
was because we had so few women CEOs we
didn't take it for granted but I think
we have to get more women in leadership
in order to do that we need to help
those talented women in the pipeline
feel that they can continue to advance
without sacrificing
important things to them in life they
don't have to sacrifice their career nor
do they have to sacrifice their family I
think that more men ought to take on
some of those family responsibilities
that was important to me I always felt
there was a reason for two parents and
my husband did a great deal and so we
could lead more balanced lives I think
that to me is the frontier is what we do
about work and family work-life balance
and if we crack that we will see all
those talented women taking on
responsibilities and it will look
completely normal to have women do
important leadership tasks
you